in an outlying district of Donna's
capital city across an on CD makes a
remarkable product he is a coffin maker
and in this part of Ghana coffins are
something special
this chili pepper coffin was built for a
restaurant owner this passenger plane
for an international businessman the
lion commemorates a powerful tribal
chief of the rooster humble farmer each
coffin celebrates the life of a loved
one I think I need more work for
customers sometimes that's for something
new then it can't be rushed
think about the design the people here
believe a funeral is the culmination of
a person's entire life and that it's
preferable to incur lifelong deaths than
to cut back on funeral expenses these
fantasy coffins have been exhibited in
art galleries throughout the world but
they are only created by a handful of
harbingers all based in this single
district his father Kani Kwai pioneered
Fantasy coffins in the 1950s and passed
the business on to his son a nouns
workshop will turn out around a hundred
fantasy cartons of year prices begin at
about $400 a considerable expense for
the meager earnings of most demands
today anon is delivering a special
commission an exclusive design for a
powerful local woman a banana shaped
coffin for a banana seller the deceased
is Madame Stahl a male a better
as Gladys she started life as a
vegetable seller but she found fame as a
priestess donnas priestesses are
guardians of a religion which sprang
from a landscape long since disappeared
a world of sacred groves and forests
priestesses from all over the capital
have come to pay their last respects to
one of their own Gladys's body is put on
display to allow family and friends to
publicly express their grief it's also
an opportunity to ask Gladys to pass on
messages and complaints to the spirits
of dead friends and relatives
Gladys his daughter-in-law tells her how
much she will be missed
[Music]
going without food or water for the
duration of the ceremony the priestesses
danced themselves into a trance
occasionally becoming possessed by
spirits from another world
led by Gladys's sons the coffin makes
its way toward her final resting place a
fitting tribute to a remarkable life